foreign
[Music]
days back in 2014 when I took my first
set of courses over the years I have
taken 11 courses from Simply learned
they have to enhance my overall
understanding
and open doors to many professional
opportunities hi I'm Dean today I live
in Bulgaria I'm currently working with a
german-based Biblical I.T company as a
Solutions architect I landed this job
because of the devops certification that
I completed in November last year
and myself
my M2 up skill has never been to get a
new job or promotion but to learn
Instead This is why I started my
upskilling journal in 2014 when I was
working in the service Management Center
I took courses in idle and portrait
management but it was in 2020 in the
middle of the pandemic when I got time
to do more courses I took courses in
cyber security and artificial
intelligence I like to learn so whenever
I decide to take a new course I know
where to go I choose to learn because
the course is provided are great value
for money and it is flexible which is
really helpful for working professional
like me in fact I just completed
professional certificate program in
blockchaining association with higher ed
camper could simply learn blockchain
results a very old problem of slow and
insecure payments done online
it also eliminates how our burden in the
process in a very elegant way I have
recently put the certification on my
your profile entities gaining a lot of
attention when people ask me about my
hobbies I told them that her upskilling
is my hobby I have started another
course in cyber security from Simply
learn I think I have been able to get
all these certifications because I kept
my passion for hot skating alive you
should also keep the passion for
learning a life
[Music]